- This is the agency that is
gonna teach the next generation
how to do the new form
of creative. It's cool.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)
Good afternoon.
Couple weeks ago or a month ago
I thought it would be good idea
to get a lot of the creative
leaders in the company together.
But what I want to accomplish
here through the four or five
hours of discussion is actually
just to get us collectively
hearing the discussion.
I want to basically
have conversations of things
that I'm seeing a lot.
A lot of what I think 2017 has
been about at VaynerMedia was
somewhere around September and
October of last year it just
became obvious to me that the
organization had become too far
away from what I thought needed
to be done in output of work and
cultural in many different
facets and I think collectively
a series of events whether it's
the reorg or different things or
when I spoke at the end of the
year last year and made it a
very short end of the year
talk about we're to be the best
Facebook commercial,
that whole thing.
A lot of my energy
is in that direction.
I want to continue it to be
in that direction so to this
collective today is not to talk
about structure or job titles or
responsibilities, I want
to talk about the work.
I want to spend the entire time
here talking about the work,
what does the
work look like to you,
and I really want
people to participate.
You know will get into jams
of like good or interesting or
opportunities or other things
you've seen but ultimately what
I want to do is have the
discussion be the output of
today and then I'll take it back
to the lab and decide if there's
things that I want to do or
don't do but I think it's good
to be very healthy for a lot of
people to hear other people's
points of view or thoughts
or dreams or aspirations
of what we do here.
And I really want to set the
tone on a couple of the pillars
and where were going to go so
why don't we go
around and say hello.
Let's go counterclockwise
'cause I think that's funny.
Juliet 'cause you're looking in
your bag why don't you start.
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)
I want to make sure
that we walk around with
the audacity
that we should have,
not worrying about being
treated like the below the line,
afterthought,
(censored) always sets the tone
and I don't care.
Now, that's easy for me 'cause
I'm playing the
long game, right?
But I'd like to
empower and please,
figure out what you
need to not care as well.
When I feel those vibes,
especially from another agency,
I laugh at it.
You have to understand
once the television commercial
marketplace collapses,
the entire above the line
traditional agency world goes
through massive disruption no
different than bookstores and
limousine services had to
when their markets
collapsed because of innovation.
And so this is a very important
time for us 'cause here's why,
we have to, at all costs, become
the organization that is most
known for making the modern-day
mobile commercial whether that
is in Facebook where I've been
sending a lot of the energy or
for a lot of brands here that
are targeting 30 and under,
I've become increasingly
fascinated with the interstitial
Snapchat ad that allows you to
swipe up and then watch a three,
four, five, six minute video and
if you look at the macro data of
the depth of consumption in that
platform on long form video once
swiped up, it's scary.
So to me, I'd like to put in
the bucket of
long form mobile video.
You know, I think one thing that
people are not spending enough
time on is
everybody's lazy, right?
Everybody's lazy.
Everybody lazily reads headlines
that and thinks that you been in
every one of you been in a
meeting in the last six months
when talking about
video for the mobile device,
people think it
needs to be short.
That it need to be
15 or 30 seconds, right?
First of all, this
whole notion of 15,
30 and 60 is ludicrous.
It is completely format based on
how television eventually formed
itself and the thought that we
should ever even be thinking
about that in this new
environment is ludicrous.
I want to make
sure we know that.
Number two, get
yourself educated,
get to the
analytics team, go read.
Long form video works on
mobile devices and I want you to
push back when you're in a room
and they go that is to be a
10 second video
or a 15 second video.
Like, two, three, four,
five minute videos work.
They just have to be good.
Today we're in a weird little
limbo that I would say we're 20%
all the way through, right?
And tomorrow we're gonna be on
the right side of this equation.
And so, I just think the
advertising world that we all
grew up with or
we're passionate about
is unbelievably on its
last breath and
I'll tell you why.
It doesn't just start
and end with traditional.
I would tell you that I believe
that almost the far majority the
of digital advertising
is straight garbage.
So I look at print and outdoors
modern version as
a Facebook picture.
I love the idea
we went (censored)
we would live in a (censored).
We want an
opportunity with (censored).
If we won the
social AOR (censored),
if we did, if we got
it now we're taking over,
the first three months, two
months if our pictures on there
are with purpose to get to
creative insights both quant and
qual, I love the idea that our
video work starts at month three
because we did work to get us
insights not just relied on our
insights team or a brief
and the way we interpret it.
We actually used quant, reason
my content works so well is
I respond to the content
and then make more content.
And so it's an inexpensive way
for us not to waste the clients'
money for the first two months,
(censored) you put a bunch of
stuff, you see what actually
works that's then along with the
insights team, the pillars in
where we create the four videos.
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)
We are a winning
digital creative shop.
This is about winning it all.
This is not a conversation.
Like, please nobody leave
here with like whoa is me.
You know how
bad it is out there?
Like we're winning.
It's just we're not gonna
win the game that's coming and
that's my responsibility, right?
That's ultimately
my responsibility.
So that's what I'm
really focused on here.
We're winning
because guess what,
every agency only cares about
the subjective call of this and
not respecting the context of
the platforms and working off of
the digital asset interpretation
of the 30 second spot and
mailing it in and just doing
it for programmatic media
that nobody sees that all.
There's no shop that is devoted
to being a disproportionately
talented video creative shop
in a Facebook
environment pot committed.
That's what I want us to be.
This is the agency that is gonna
teach the next generation how to
do the new form of creative.
It's cool.
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)
You want to be successful?
You Google things, you
Google things like how to make a
Facebook video go viral with the
first three seconds or
what's good in
the first five seconds.
Get smart.
The first article ever written
about me in my career was in the
Star Ledger in New Jersey.
New Jersey's state
paper and it was titled,
"Grape Expectations".
(group laughter)
And it was it was
written about this
25-year-old kid who launched a
website and has now built one of
the biggest liquor stores
in the country right here in
Springfield, New Jersey and
there's a very long quote from
me in the article.
You can probably Google this.
And fuck man, I can't believe
how fun this is about the say.
In it they
interview me and they go,
"What's the
secret of Wine Library?"
And I go, "One of the three
most successful wholesalers,
"these are people you buy your
wine from who's the legendary
"guy, who's the
smart guy of the three."
You know, one of
them was family inherited,
the other one supposedly
lucky-ish but I don't believe in
that but this was the smart one.
This was the guy that really
was thoughtful and was smart.
In it my quote is, one of them
sat down with me at dinner the
first year I started
running Wine Library.
I started making some
changes and he sat me down,
he asked me for dinner and this
was supposed to be a big deal.
It was an honor for me to have
this dinner with
this legendary wholesaler.
And halfway through
the dinner he says to me,
"Gary, running a successful wine
shop takes three things:
"price, selection and
service and what you,
"young man, have to figure out
this year is which two of those
"three you're gonna focus on to
build a successful business."
This is me telling the story and
then I say and in that moment is
a 22-year-old kid I said in
my head this guy's a fucking
asshole and I'm a
do three out of three.
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)
The brand team sits
down and they go oh,
we've got a tough budget year.
It's gonna be a tough
year, we have no money.
And they said
they had $2 million and
it seemed like a fortune.
We are absolutely
in a fucking bubble,
my friends.
I'm just gonna remind
you, there's two young women,
they're in Savannah, and
they're gonna fucking kill you.
You know why?
They can do a lot
of shit with (censored)
and we don't think we can.
Please help me
change that culture.
(group applause)
You know what's fun about that?
Somebody just said it to me,
we're all on the same page now.
Like meaning make the
fucking videos we want to make,
be smart, work with each other.
It's just great to get that,
getting us all grounded.
- [Man] I was just gonna say
allowing for a platform where
people could talk that
enabled you to hone in on that.
- Uh-huh.
Big, right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like doing the work in real
time in front of everybody.
- [Man] Exactly.
- [Man 2] With
real world examples.
I think that was the most
powerful stuff there that I got.
Literally taking
exact examples and going,
well here, I'd tweak that,
I'd tweak that.
That's bullshit, who cares?
And then just the
dialog that surrounds that.
I think that at least for me,
specific examples of it.
Got it,
now I can extrapolate that.
We can take that in a
100 different directions.
- [Gary] People don't get
it and it's not your
fault they're not getting it.
It's that I have to figure out
more and different and
intriguing ways
to articulate it.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- And this was one of them.
And maybe this
was the one that got,
you know?
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- [Gary] You chip away.
- I think it probably
was for a lot of people.
- [Gary] I think so too.
I mean I think, look, just
getting everybody aligned on
things at a moment in time so
all the different fractions
can't speak to
the way it used to be,
the way it's gonna be,
the way we interpret it,
that was pretty crystal clear.
Honestly, if I just leave with
everybody making videos in those
six formats or genres like
to the best of their fucking
ability that will be
a game changer for us.
It will work.
("Should've Called
PRT 2" by Jimi Tents)